we start today with a major story
the wife of supreme court justice
clarence thomas jenny thomas
we now know
was way more involved in the lead up to
and supporting the attempts to overthrow
the correct
accurate real winner of the 2020
presidential election she was involved
in emails with donald trump's attorneys
she was involved in emails with arizona
lawmakers who were trying to figure out
a way remember this
alternate slate of electors that they
wanted to send to washington dc
ginny thomas was extremely involved and
we now know it now we suspected this for
months because of little bits of data
and evidence here and there
but now
thanks to the january 6th committee the
degree to which ginny thomas was
involved and we must wonder
what about clarence thomas i mean is it
is it really plausible that he has no
idea what she's up to and not at all
supportive of what she's up to it starts
to become hard to believe so let's go to
the primary report about this from the
washington post
ginny thomas corresponded with john
eastman sources in the january 6th house
investigation say
the house committee investigating the
january 6 attacks has obtained email
correspondence between jenny thomas the
wife of clarence thomas and lawyer john
eastman who played a key role in efforts
to pressure vice president pence to
block the certification of joe biden's
victory this is according to three
people involved in the investigation
remember eastman's the guy
who wrote the memo
telling mike pence uh or rather wrote
the memo explaining how mike pence could
reject the election results and send it
back to the states as they love to say
none of this is true none of this is
real none of this is based on real in
reality but that's who john eastman is
and jenny thomas was corresponding
directly with him
the article goes on to say the emails
show that thomas's effort to overturn
the election were more extensive than
previously known
the three declined to provide details
and spoke on the condition of anonymity
the committee staffers and members are
now discussing whether to spend time
during the public hearings exploring
jenny thomas's role in trying to
overturn the outcome of the 2020
election the washington post previously
reported the committee had not sought an
interview with thomas and was leaning
against pursuing her cooperation the two
people said the emails were among
documents obtained and reviewed recently
last week a federal judge ordered
eastman to turn more than a hundred
documents over to the committee eastman
was trying to block those
thomas also sent messages to president
trump's white house chief of staff mark
meadows that this is ginny thomas was in
touch with eastman
mark meadows and to arizona lawmakers
pressing them to help overturn the
election
thomas has maintained she and her
husband operate in separate professional
lanes
her activities as a conservative
political activist have long
distinguished her from other spouses of
supreme court justices
any new revelations about her actions
after the 2020 election are likely to
further intensify questions about
whether thomas clarence thomas should
recuse himself from cases related to the
election and attempt to subvert it
this is a major major deal one other
piece of this that i wanted to mention
to you
um
about the arizona
element
um
she was in touch with 27 ah here we go
in the weeks after the 2020 election
jenny thomas repeatedly pressed mark
meadows to overturn the outcome as if he
can do it she told meadows in a text she
was disgusted with pence who didn't
block the certification of biden's
victory she said we are living through
what feels like the end of america and
then during the same period she was
pressing republican lawmakers in arizona
to help keep trump in office by setting
aside biden's popular vote win and
choosing their own electors which is
completely and absolutely bonkers so
this is truly madness
now
there are reports that liz cheney who's
on the january 6 committee
has been hesitant or resisting really
pulling in jenny thomas into part of the
investigation
but these are absolutely questions that
americans deserve to see answered
publicly particularly particularly if
elements of the january 6 riots may come
before the supreme court
um i'm not sure about you know this it
would be a waste of time to bring ginny
thomas in well i don't know about that
but the involvement of jenny thomas
needs to be looked at completely and it
is it it's damning that clarence thomas
did not recuse himself on the january 6
document production case that made its
way to the supreme court think about it
on the one hand his wife is out there
involved in trying to make certain
things happen on january 6th
and also is mentioned in all sorts of
the documents that are at issue that so
his wife is relate she is a party to
many of these documents and
communications
and he then gets to decide whether it's
appropriate or not whether it's legally
justified or not for documents to be
released and turned over that's
outrageous it's completely outrageous
and just think for a second
imagine that it was sonia sotomayor's
husband
who was in a similar situation who had
been texting and emailing and pushing
for the election to be given to someone
other than the person who actually won
do you think republicans would be silent
no
it would be 24 7 on fox news
the hunter biden laptop story which is
almost nothing look at how much coverage
that received imagine if uh you know a
family member of elena kagan was it it's
outrageous and um this has to be
explored and there are so many
extremists listen they're not just close
to the government they're in government
as well but even on the periphery of
government and on the periphery of power
they are everywhere and it is very
difficult to believe here we're making a
judgment call i don't know that much
about uh ginny and clarence thomas's
relationship but do we really believe
that jenny thomas is this involved she's
contacting lawmakers she's in touch with
the president's chief of staff
uh she's in touch with john eastman and
clarence thomas knows nothing has no
opinion and is completely neutral about
what she's doing right like imagine that
hey clarence i'm in touch with eastman
i'm in touch with meadows i'm trying to
keep trump in power i'm trying to push
for a different slate of electors to be
sent from arizona and clarence thomas
goes oh that's really interesting i have
no opinion one way or the other about
what you're doing give me a break guys
and i know there are some weird
relationships in washington dc but it is
very difficult to imagine that that's
the case now
at this point
what i would
i mean you know we talk about taking the
high road taking the low road democrats
should do what republicans would do if
the situation was reversed
go to them and go to thomas and say
listen clarence thomas needs to go
clarence thomas should resign
we'll have joe biden pick a right
leaning justice so it won't change the
balance of the court and then ram
through a progressive in the middle of
the night this is what this is what
republicans would do okay
and this is what democrats should do if
you disagree with me let me know
one of the big questions about the 2022
midterm elections has been as we get
past the primaries
what do the general elections look like
pennsylvania is a great example in
pennsylvania we had very prominent
primaries uh for the governor's race uh
this guy doug mastriano who is
essentially a a big lie
a january sixth rioter that that's
essentially what he is uh doug
masteriano won the republican primary
for governor in pennsylvania and will
now face josh shapiro but the question
is well how is that race looking uh in
the republican senate race mehmet oz was
endorsed by trump one ultimately won a
very very close primary but the question
is how is oz faring against john
fetterman the overwhelming victor in the
democratic primary for the pennsylvania
senate what does it look like for
november we finally have those numbers
and it really depends on whether you
want to be a glass half full or glass
half empty sort of person
when it comes to these poles whether we
say that it's looking good or that it's
not looking good so let's look at the
polls which we've been waiting for for a
long time
the post-gazette reports democrats john
fetterman and josh shapiro lead
republicans memit oz and doug mastriano
in the first big pennsylvania general
election poll okay that's good the
democrats are winning for uh the general
election well but how much well
this is where it's maybe not quite so
good
in the senate contest democratic
candidate john fetterman pennsylvania
sitting lieutenant governor is up by
nine over republican member oz the
celebrity cardio thoracic surgeon that's
46 to 37 with 13 percent of respondents
undecided okay that's the senate race in
the race for governor democrat josh
shapiro the state attorney general leads
republican doug mastriano a state
senator by a slimmer margin by 4 44 to
40 with 13 percent of respondents again
declaring themselves undecided okay so
we have the numbers are these numbers
good or are these numbers bad i can
genuinely make two completely different
cases to you about this let me make to
you
the most optimistic case
the republican primaries got way more
attention than the democratic primaries
josh shapiro was unopposed john
fetterman was expected to easily win and
he did despite all of the attention on
the republican primaries the democrats
are still winning
josh shapiro is arguably much less
well-known than doug mastriano he didn't
have any kind of like major endorsement
that i'm aware of like masteriano had
trumps and despite all of that all of
that attention all of the name
recognition the democrats are still
winning and they're winning both races
great okay but wow david sir thank you
for the optimistic case
now what's the pessimistic case well the
pessimistic case
is uh fetterman
is winning by nine but there's 13
percent undecided and pennsylvania is
although it has typically typically
leaned blue to the left
um it doesn't always and 13 undecided is
not particularly good and 9 is not a
comfortable lead there and then when you
look at the gubernatorial race you can
make an even more pessimistic case which
is wait a second
despite the fact that masteriano
is quite literally a rioter in the sense
that he allegedly
uh
passed and breached police barricades in
dc on january 6. despite that he's only
losing by four
with 13 percent undecided that's a
disaster
because the general campaigns are only
just starting this is really not good
now which of the two
cases do i lean towards i lean slightly
to the pessimistic case we have a
situation in the united states right now
where mastriano was a participant at the
insurrection he spent over three
thousand dollars to bus over a hundred
trump supporters to dc on january six he
was seen crossing police barricades uh
despite denying it and even despite all
of that
he's only losing by four and thirteen
percent are still undecided because we
are in an era where these things are no
longer disqualifying think of the
hollywood accent the access hollywood
tape with donald trump in the past that
would have ended many elected officials
or potential elected officials careers
and trump went on to become president of
the united states and almost to get
himself re-elected so
is it better that the two democrats in
pennsylvania are winning rather than
losing of course it's better they were
losing it would be an even bigger
disaster
but these leads particularly the
masteriano lead the master the josh
shapiro lead over mastriano rather these
are not comfortable leads in any sense
so when we think about where is there a
race that we can really kind of make a
difference and we've talked about this
whole marcus flowers versus margaery
taylor green thing marcus flowers is a
fine candidate against marjory taylor
green in georgia but as many people have
written in
it's not really likely that being such a
red district pouring money in for marcus
flowers or phone banking is going to
remove marjorie taylor green and i i
never say give up on a race but it is
statistically true that that's a big
uphill battle
if efforts were concentrated on the
really important races this one in
pennsylvania could be huge because
number one fetterman versus oz could
decide who controls the senate for the
next two years
and the governor of pennsylvania
could decide who wins pennsylvania uh in
2024 the real winner or whoever doug
mastriano wants to see these are really
consequential races does it not make
more sense to put our efforts there it's
a question that we're going to have to
figure out as we get closer to november
and then into 2024. let me know what you
think find me on twitter at dpakman but
at least they're not losing that's what
we can say so far
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
the david pakman show is an audience
supported independent media program i
would love for you to sign up on my
website joinpakman.com we do an extra
show every day for our website
subscribers and you can use the coupon
code big voting 22 to get yourself a
discount off of the cost of a membership
at
joinpacman.com we have a new controversy
as we continue learning more thanks to
the january 6th trump riot committee the
new controversy involves republican
congressman barry loudermilk who is now
being accused of having led a tour
a reconnaissance tour for future
would-be trump rioters before january 6.
now of course he's denying it he says it
was all on the up and up and he gave a
bizarre interview to fox news's laura
ingraham which we're going to look at in
a moment but first let me catch you up
on what it is that is being alleged um
barry loudermilk says that the tour he
gave
was not a reconnaissance tour for future
rioters taking pictures of the security
settings uh the security situation and
tunnels and security cameras but rather
it was um people who just wanted to take
pictures of children's artwork that's
what he says now we'll see if we believe
him newsweek week reporting
representative barry lowdermilk said a
group he took through the capitol
complex on january 5th
were simply taking pictures of artwork
and he rejects the insinuation that he
led a reconnaissance tour on the eve of
the insurrection on wednesday yesterday
the january 6 committee wanted an
explanation from him about surveillance
footage showing him taking a group
through the complex with a man seen
photographing security points and
stairwells and the video is pretty weird
the committee has shared footage
purportedly showing the same man who was
taking the pictures
threatening top democrats
after the riots on january 6th by
supporters of ex-president trump some
republicans were accused by democrats of
giving tours to people who later went on
to storm the capital
while the congressional committee has
requested a meeting with loudermilk u.s
capitol police concluded there is no
evidence he led a tour with trump
supporters trying to learn more about
the complex
on monday capitol police chief tom
manager manger wrote in a letter we do
not consider any of the activities we
observed as suspicious loudermilk told
fox news yesterday the conclusion of the
police doesn't fit the narrative the
january 6 committee wants to come up
with it is a very strange coincidence
that being said
that
supposedly the person he gave a tour to
the day before the riot was then seen
rioting at the capitol that is weird so
let's go to the interview that
loudermilk gave to fox news's laura
ingram
he says they were taking pictures of
children's artwork see if you think he
is telling the truth yeah i mean people
who come to washington dc like these
people who have never been there before
right they're excited
they're taking pictures is it against
protocol or rules to take photos in the
lower level where they were no not
anywhere except for right around the
house chambers that's the only place
that there's no there's no restrictions
in doing this no absolutely not people
take pictures there all the time now in
the video that they show and i know that
if you're listening you won't be able to
see this
it's certainly not evident that the
things that are being photographed
are all you know children's artwork
and also is
is children's artwork that interesting
guys i mean listen i uh
i'm not at the point in fatherhood where
there's any artwork being produced but
i've been around lots of people whose
kids produce artwork
and
it would never really occur to me to
photograph uh kids artwork and also he
initially said that he didn't lead any
tours anyway
and then he said that he never heard
from the committee about answering
questions when they actually did contact
him so he has told multiple lies and
it's weird that people who the next day
show up at the riot are that interested
in children's artwork it just doesn't
pass the sniff test for me why doesn't
the january 6 committee show the entire
video because they're taking pictures
all up and down the hallway when the
guys near the tunnels going to the
capitol that's where they hang the
artwork that school children give and at
the other end there is the trolleys the
trains and the kids wanted to see the
trains that take the congressman to the
house chambers that's all this was and
the capitol police they know this all
right so that's his claim
it's weird i mean
something about this doesn't doesn't
really make sense
uh let's go to the next clip sure but
loudermilk has to come and he has to
testify to clear this up do you know
anything about the guy
taking the photo and is is he some
nefarious character not that i know of i
mean i did not know everybody who was in
the group as most members of congress
why won't you go testify they say uh
they haven't asked me to so that
he says they haven't asked him
the reports are that he has been asked
and so it appears that that's a lie they
keep asking you guys
to have me come they keep releasing this
stuff to the media but they don't send
me the letters okay that as far as we
know that's not true the interview
continues
ringleader in this whole exactly and
what they're not showing is what was the
guy taking a picture of there is a
golden eagle
on the wall right upside that stairwell
that's holding two candles right that's
why he's taking a picture of people take
pictures of that all the time that's all
it is except in all the footage this guy
is taking pictures even when they seem
to be going through security checkpoints
and it's not obvious that there's i mean
listen if an eagle holding candles is
that compelling if a if a kid's art
piece of artwork is that compelling okay
but there are videos where it's not
clear that there's any artwork on the
wall uh he wonders why he is being
targeted
but what the capitol police said doesn't
fit the narrative that the january 6
committee wants to come up with why
they've targeted me i don't know right
now of course the reason he may be
targeted or the reason that he has
raised eyebrows is he initially said he
didn't lead a tour and then video of him
leading a tour came out and then he's
claiming he hasn't been asked to come
testify except the committee says no we
we did ask him to come and then lastly
he says he will not change his story a
principled and defiant barry loudermilk
he won't change his story because he
must stand for the truth except he's
already changed his story the first
story was i didn't lead a tour now it's
i did but it was all fine guns if
there's pressure i mean come on has
anyone pressured you to to change your
story about this oh no absolutely not
and i won't because there is a war on
the truth in this country right now and
he's one of the people who has been
caught lying we have to stand for the
truth the easiest thing for me to do
would just been lay down and go dark i'm
not going to do that we have to stand
for truth and right if we're going to if
we're going to save this country right
it depends the country's
if he
guys i mean we can't
he's been caught lying multiple times
that's why people are focusing on you
okay there were members of congress who
early said oh yeah i led a tour i led a
tour here there here's you who showed up
none of the people in the tour later
showed up at the riots this guy denied
leading a tour then the video came out
one of the people who was on the tour
ended up at the capitol on january 6.
he's been caught in multiple lies he's
changing his story already while
simultaneously saying i will not change
my story that's extraordinarily
suspicious so let me know
do you believe him do you i mean it's
it's something is weird about his story
but maybe it rings true to you let me
know what you think a dr anthony fauci
has covid
and donald trump's former doctor now
congressman ronnie jackson is just
thrilled he is gleeful he's bursting at
the seams with excitement that dr
anthony fauci has covered now we we
learned about this in the last couple
days yesterday i guess it was dr anthony
fauci tests positive for covid is
experiencing mild symptoms
he's 81 years old he's fully vaccinated
he's been boosted twice he has mild
symptoms and will isolate and work from
home he's taking paxlivid the anti-covet
drug
um and will follow the guidelines of the
cdc okay so well he's an 81 year old not
an age that you necessarily
love to get covered at
but he's doing okay what does
congressman ronnie jackson tweet
i think you all know
ronnie jackson tweets quote sad to see
that despite vaccines boosters multiple
masks and social distancing fauchi has
contracted covid i hope you get well
very soon exclamation point i mean a
more more sarcastic well wishes are hard
to imagine you'll need to be in tip-top
shape when the republican majority takes
congress lots of testifying while under
investigation
next year
it's great to see
that a fellow doctor i mean guys think
think about how disgusting this ronnie
jackson guy is
a fellow doctor oh i hope you're gonna
need to be in tip-top shape i hope you
get well soon because you're gonna be
under investigation when we take over
next year now statistically
statistically dr fauci has mild symptoms
because he's vaccinated and boosted
81 year olds
unvaccinated who get coveted
have statistically worse outcomes
significantly worse outcomes that's a
very at-risk group 80 plus i think it's
75 plus in fact and so you can never
make any claim about an individual right
you so when when someone dies
unvaccinated we can't say
they would have survived if they were
vaccinated we don't know that we can
just talk in large numbers statistically
speaking someone who died unvaccinated
would have had a much better shot had
they been vaccinated so all we can say
about dr fauci is statistically an
unvaccinated 81 year old would fare
worse against the virus
than someone who has been vaccinated and
boosted and speaking of that since we
haven't talked about covid for a while
there's a really interesting new study
in the journal health affairs which
actually looked at the partisan divide
on covet mortality we've talked
generally before about this and before
i've told you you know if you just
generally take a look at covet deaths in
trump voting counties versus biden
voting counties there's definitely a
correlation where the trump voting
county counties have more deaths per
capita this has now been studied and
this is this is a very good study the
study is called the association between
covet 19 mortality
and the county level partisan divide in
the united states and when you look at
the abstract the results are very clear
the abstract says we found a positive
dose response relationship between
county level republican vote share and
county level covet 19 mortality this
means the higher
trump vote
the more coveted death majority
republican counties experienced 73
additional deaths per 100 000 people
relative to the majority democratic
counties during the study period and
covid vaccine uptake explains
approximately 10 percent of the
different difference now that's
interesting as well
vaccination is only one part of why the
death rate is higher in republican
counties because the abstract goes on to
say our findings suggest that county
level voting behavior may act as a proxy
for compliance with and support of
public health measures that would
protect residents from covet 19. so
bottom line what their what they found
is
you look at republican counties and
democratic counties
republican counties have a higher death
rate from covid
partially that's explained by the
republican counties having a lower
vaccination rate but partially it's
explained by less adherence to public
health guidelines in those republican
counties which presumably includes
masking social distancing etc not a
shock
not a shock we intuitively knew this
early on
we saw general data pointing this way
early on and now we have an actual
proper study about it not a shock
uh we wish dr fauci our best and hope he
recovers soon and you can find more on
all of these stories on the david pakman
show instagram that's at davidpakmanshow
on instagram
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com david pakman show today
we're going to be speaking with gary
stevenson who's an inequality economist
and former interest rates trader uh gary
really great having you on i appreciate
your time
thanks for having me
so i mean maybe just to to start with a
little bit about your background
interest rates trading how how does that
work and with whom are you trading
okay so i worked as an interest rate
trader from 2008 to 2014 at citibank
just hearing a skyscraper off to my left
um
2008 you probably remember with the year
of the great financial crisis yes at
that time all the interest rates in the
whole world went to zero so as an
interest rates trader my job was
basically to bet on when will those
interest rates come back up again which
is kind of a proxy for when will the
economy recover
um
you expect that when the economy
recovers we get demand coming back and
rates start to come back up what's
interesting about that is
every single year from 2008 to 2020
markets predicted that rates would
renormalize the following year which was
wrong almost every single year so um i
made a lot of money by betting that they
would stay zero for a long time
one of the criticisms that many will
make about um
that that type of industry
is that it is not economically
stimulative in the way that making shoes
and selling shoes to someone who then
then wears them is right this is a
common criticism that we hear about
derivatives trading and and financial
markets wall street etc having been
inside of it how do you feel about that
claim that trading interest rates
compared to for example running a
restaurant or a dry cleaning business or
manufacturing eyeglasses are
fundamentally different in terms of what
they do for the economy yeah listen you
won't get much argument from me i'm
afraid i didn't go into that industry to
be economically productive or
stimulative i went into industry because
i was really poor and i didn't want to
be poor anymore right and um from that
perspective it worked um
what i would say is you know i've worked
in economics for a long time now in a
lot of different spaces so i've worked
in finance
i've got a master's degree from oxford
university here in england i've been in
media talking about economics for a
while now i've been sort of bouncing
around sort of activism think tanks and
what i will say is
the markets are the only place where
somebody like me can be the number one
guy within a couple of years
because if you're really really good and
you're right year after year you get
noticed and you know i put an article
out two years ago at the beginning of
kobe saying that
we're going to see at the end of cobit a
massive crisis of inequality of
inflation of cost of living and i put a
video on youtube saying the same thing
those predictions
were exactly correct
now i did the same thing when i was
working as a trader and within a year
two years you're famous but in this
world if you're right
people are not really risen to the top
so what i would say is
trading is an interesting space because
a young guy a poor background can get
famous by being right in economics and
there's not that many spaces where you
can do that outside of that
so you mentioned inequality and i want
to focus in on that a little bit
you know
sometimes discussions about inequality
particularly in in the uk in the united
states the conversations become sort of
like ethical and moral conversations uh
do does does a wealthy country have a
responsibility or a duty to provide some
bottom some floor to standard of living
and who has earned what or who deserves
what that's one side of the discussion
and different people might have
different feelings about that
i've also argued from an economic and
financial standpoint that there should
be an incentive for the wealthy uh to
also guarantee some minimum standard of
living and reduce inequality because
it's also if you consider a sort of
demand side stimulus approach it's also
good for the rich people it's good for
the businesses it's good to have more
potential customers who can afford
whatever it is that you're selling and
having reduced inequality
reduces crime it reduces a lot of other
costs now i i would still make a moral
and ethical case as well
but i want to explore maybe the
financial and economic case to be made
does that track with your beliefs about
the damaging reality of inequality
yeah 100 i mean look i don't come from a
political family i didn't want to be an
activist i didn't want to be a political
youtuber which in a sense is what i've
become
um but my job was to bet on the future
of the global economy
and
i worked in an industry where every
single year
the markets as a whole said next year
things will get better and for the first
three years i worked in the industry
things didn't get better
um and you know this is a problem right
like if you if you have a doctor who
says every patient is going to get
better and the patients keep dying
you've got a problem right because these
guys the economist and it's not just
traders it's also guys in central banks
in government in academia they keep
saying things are going to get better
and things don't get better right so
it's clearly a fundamental problem then
for me
you know i i thought a lot about what
what is the reason why we're not getting
the recovery basically what is the
fundamental reason i think
i think actually one of the reasons why
i was able to be such a successful
trader and at one point i was citibank's
most profitable trader in the world is
because i actually am one of the few
traders who comes from a very poor
background so in the after the 2008
financial crisis when we weren't getting
that recovery
we had to ask this question of why
aren't people spending more money
well i was one of the few people who
could go and ask my friends and family
ordinary people why aren't you spending
more money and listen ask people now
nine times out of ten you'll get the
same answer because we don't have any
more money right
and if if the vast majority of people
don't have any extra money to spend you
are going to have economic crisis of
demand
and that's where we've been for you know
15 years essentially so
for me
this is and of course you're 100 right
when you say that there's a moral
ethical argument here but there's also a
100 plain economic argument and
i'm not just saying this from a mold
standpoint i've made millions of pounds
betting on this if you do not deal with
inequality it is inevitable that your
economy will decline and decline over
time
i'm curious
do you have a sense of the the
prevailing political views amongst the
who the people that were your fellow
traders i mean was was it a sort of
supply-side right-leaning group of
people were what was it like
so
trading is an elite profession in the
sense that it's one of the best paid
professions you can you can get into
so for that reason
nowadays very very few people get in who
are not from originally pretty wealthy
backgrounds so you're getting people
coming in generally who are quite
wealthy
a lot of them have got economics degrees
and i think when someone has an
economics theory they tend to have kind
of
absorbed into themselves some certain
ideas which which you might describe as
quite right-wing ideas um
but at the same time and what i think is
interesting about trading is these guys
are very very
strongly rewarded for being right and
harshly punished for being wrong
so i think especially people who i
worked with
you know
i've said it here i was one of the most
probable traders at the bank and i was
very vocal about it i would say look we
are never going to get an economic
recovery because of a crisis of
inequality you know and i was saying
that in 2010 2011. so obviously people
who are working with me then
they see that i've been right for 10 11
12 years
um in that world
the main thing is that you have to be
right
so i think people who i've worked with
tend to
you know eventually they see these guys
want to make money and they see the guy
who's right every year and that's me so
they come around to my point of view
which is okay inequality is killing the
economy the problem is inequality is not
killing the economy for everyone right
for rich people inequality is absolutely
fantastic and these guys are making half
a million pounds a year a million pounds
a year
so
as much as they can see that there's a
disaster happening they're not the best
incentivized to fix it
when it comes to reducing inequality
um
there's a lot of different ideas and
approaches they're often very much tied
into one's prevailing political beliefs
and it's not just a question of what
does the economics necessarily show
what sort of framework or approach
do you think would be the most effective
so i think there's there's basically two
two ways to answer that question one is
what would be technically the most
effective way to reduce inequality and
one is what is politically achievable
okay because this is a really like hot
political conversation right now the
thing which i generally tend to advocate
for is a wealth tax because i think that
is the one which we're most likely to
get people on board with but you know
there are loads of ways you could reduce
inequality you know you could for
example bring in
you could encourage or force the rich to
spend much much much more money which
would drive wages up and give us an
economic boom you know this would be
effective as well but i think what's
important to understand is
in the absence of intervention
inequality rises super super quickly and
this is like a very simple thing which i
think people need to understand
when people have high amounts of wealth
that wealth makes wealth so if somebody
has say 100 million dollars they're
gonna make in an average year three five
million dollars from that money
so these guys will get much much richer
over time and you know in the first year
of kobe i think the first two years the
average billionaire doubled their wealth
in the u.s so these guys will get richer
if we don't do anything so i think
it's really a case of how do you prevent
the crisis from worsening but i think
you have to look at the tax system
because at the moment we have a tax
system where look i come from a poor
background i made millions of dollars i
paid 50
but if you come from a wealthy
background and you have money in the
family you can pay nothing and you can
be much much richer than i am so if you
have a system where the super rich pay
nothing and people like me pay 50
inequalities are never gonna rise
right and this is where you start to get
into resistance where you will hear sort
of like
pre-packaged talking points like for
example if you do that you will kill
innovation and the job creating wealthy
will not uh create jobs and you know
when i look at it i think to myself
the cost of hoarding the money has to be
high that's how you incentivize people
to do something more productive with the
money make it expensive to just sit and
earn the interest which sounds sort of
like what you're saying here
but look there's two ways there's two
things that you need to grow the economy
yeah of course you need people making
investments so that you can have
those productive investments in growth
but you also need demand right look i'm
a wealthy person okay i live off my
investments i live with my investment
income it is very very hard to make
productive real investments in this
economy and you know we've had
12 13 years of zero interest rates
effectively negative real interest rates
interest rates still are aggressively
negative right what that means is if you
are a rich person you cannot get any
interest on your money so there should
be huge amounts of money flooding into
investments but why aren't there it's
because the customers are not there
there's not enough customers to create
that real growth you need two things you
need two sides of the coin you need
customers who can spend and you need
people who can save and invest but when
inequality gets too high then all of
that money is flowing to the super rich
who are trying to invest it but there
are no customers at the end to spend and
you see these crisis of demand and i
think when we're in a situation of 15
years negative interest rates these
supply side arguments have to be dead
they have to be dead you would not get
15 years of negative interest rates if
the problem was not enough people
investing their money
this next question may be tough because
the current tax rates are different in
different countries and you know here in
the united states we have a progressive
income tax
and then we also have capital gains and
there's short-term capital gains and
long-term capital gains and one movement
is well tax capital gains as income
taxes which would be much higher this
would be a way to make it
to to better incentivize the rich to
spend and put that money into something
other than just collecting the gains
the tax rates are different in the uk
they're different in all these different
countries do you have some sense of what
a more realistic framework should be
about two things one
where
income tax rates should be but maybe
just as importantly capital gains
because capital gains rates being lower
is often a way for the wealthy to avoid
income taxes altogether
so i think
there's two things to think about one is
the rate
and one is avoidance largely legal
avoidance yeah so i think one thing that
needs to be recognized about capital
gains is you pay capital gains when you
sell correct so imagine you have a
wealth of 100 million dollars which
means you're making three five million
dollars income a year on your wealth are
you ever gonna sell
well you're never gonna have to sell
right you're making three five million
dollars a year income so rich people
never have to sell if you're super rich
you never have to sell so the first
thing is so you can bring the rate up to
whatever you want you know if these guys
never sell they're never going to pay
and there is a movement to say okay well
we need to tax unrealized gains
um
the most important thing is it needs to
work it needs to work in the sense of it
needs to effectively tax the very
richest in society right because i know
there are people in the middle that are
worried you're going to try and tax
super rich they're going to avoid it and
then it's going to fall on me and if
that is what happens then it will be a
failure so this needs to be rigorously
tested against does it work on the very
very rich the richest you know is jeff
bezos going to pay is elon musk going to
pay are they gonna continue to pay very
little tax on their wealth so
raising tax on capital gains raising the
rate is one thing but you need to get
rid of evasion um i think really what
you need to look at is what is
somebody's
income over the course of their whole
life and how much tax they pay that
should be the measure how much wealth
does this guy have and how much taxes he
paid and if we're talking about numbers
of less than less than 30 20 for people
who are billionaires you've messed up
and you need to fix it right is there
one particular mechanism that you have
found is most resistant to avoidance
um
to be honest the the problem is often
these taxes are brought in
with avoidance kind of in mind because
you have to consider the game the
politicians are playing on the one hand
most ordinary people actually want the
rich to pay higher taxes they don't
think it's fair that the rich pay lower
taxes than the rest of us they want
higher taxes but the political parties
are funded by super rich people who
don't want to pay taxes so how can you
make both of these groups happy what you
can do is you can bring in a tax that's
called a wealth tax but you can put
loopholes in it such that the superior
can avoid it and then everybody wins
right you can say to ordinary people we
brought the tax in and you can say to
the rich but it doesn't matter because
you don't have to pay it right so i
think there's a real problem here of
politicians you know often they
themselves are super wealthy or become
super wealthy after leaving office and
they're not well incentivized to bring
in a system that works i think you know
anything could work really a capital
gain system could work an inheritance
tax system could work i've got ideas
about putting wealth into a time limit
trust such you can only give it to your
kids for a certain amount of time all of
these things could work but they will
only work with serious political will
behind them to actually make them
effective because at the moment the
incentivization of politicians is to
pretend to tax the rich but actually not
tax the rich and that's why a lot of the
work i do is talking directly to
ordinary people because these are the
guys who have been hurt by the system
you currently have
yeah a depressing but accurate note to
end on i guess i would say uh gary
stevenson inequality economist former
interest rates trader really appreciate
your time and insights today gary
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
this next story would not be believable
if we hadn't been seeing exactly this
type of projection for the last who
knows how many years from the american
republican party uh herschel walker the
trump-endorsed republican senate
candidate from georgia
has been a big critic of absentee
fathers in fact he's run a campaign very
much based around cultural issues
critical race theory which he misstated
as ctr which is usually an abbreviation
for click-through rate which is an
online advertising term anyway he meant
crt he's been talking about crt he's
been talking about absentee fathers and
all of these different things
we had two layers of insanity first it
was revealed
that herschel walker actually has
another son he has one son that kind of
is in the public eye named christian
walker
it was revealed that herschel walker has
another son
that he doesn't see he
is an absentee father to another son
after that story came out it was
revealed that herschel walker actually
has even more kids to whom he is an
absentee father i guess we would say he
is not really a father is every
allegation a confession from these
people so let's go through it piece by
piece and then we'll talk about the
hypocrisy so first we have an article
from the new york times
this is from two days ago and the
article says kershaw walker critic of
absentee fathers has a second son that
he doesn't see the article is from maya
king
herschel walker the republican nominee
for senate from georgia who is often
spoken out against absentee fathers
particularly in black households on
tuesday publicly acknowledged having
fathered a second son with whom he is
not in contact
the admission came in response to a
report by the daily beast which said it
confirmed ten-year-old boy's parentage
but withheld his name and that of the
mother it says the child's mother has
sued walker a year after giving birth to
obtain a declaration of paternity and
child support and the suit lasted until
august 2014 when walker was ordered to
pay child support the boy by then more
than two years old took walker's last
name
okay so that's already crazy like that
that's already wow so you're going out
there saying not just in general we have
a problem with absentee fathers but in
the black community we have a problem
with absentee fathers and he is he is
part of that problem okay
but then it gets even crazier because
then this morning
another piece comes out in the daily
beast herschel walker critic of absentee
dads admits to yet another secret son
and
it's this isn't the first secret son
that was reported this is another one
this artic used by article is by roger
sullenberger and it says a day after the
daily beast broke the news that herschel
walker had a secret 10 year old son
the football star turned politician
confirmed late wednesday he has yet
another son with a different woman
as well as a daughter that he had in
college
um walker said in september of 2020 i
want to apologize to the
african-american community because the
fatherless home is a major major problem
he added in an interview with diamond
and silk men need to go into
neighborhoods and become fathers of
those fatherless children
the second of walker's previously
undisclosed sons was born to a woman
living in texas and is now 13. walker's
other son is 10
christian walker who's the publicly
known one is 22.
the daily beast is con withholding the
names of the younger sons and their
mothers
um there's a bunch of different layers
to this story okay
first it's the heavy projection that we
are constantly seeing from the
republican party um trump's of about
family values supposedly evangelicals
vote for me i love the bible and i love
two corinthians and all this different
stuff um except trump's been divorced
multiple times and he's cheated
endlessly and he has uh children with
with different women and all these
things that the evangelicals claim to
care about and trump says vote for me
anyway and then they do because they
really don't like hillary clinton okay
so like that's one layer the double
standard the hypocrisy that that's
certainly um part of this but there's
also kind of another element to this
which is
the republican party at this point only
cares about
virtue signaling around these issues
rather than actual policy and they apply
different standards to their own than to
others and this is unfortunately it's
not something that we can fix
because you can't get other people to
actually care about being consistent
you have to remember that the way the
republican party works right now is they
say it's basically this thought process
democrats are evil socialist communists
uh whatever baby killing right all the
different stuff sodomites some of them
like to say whatever it is that they say
they start with that so we absolutely
can't have any democrats in office we've
got to vote for republicans
the reason we claim that we do that is
because the republicans are pro-life and
the republicans are pro-family and
they're godly and they have faith in all
of these different things oh okay well
look at trump trump's a guy who was
pro-choice his entire life until he all
of a sudden needed to come up with some
explanation for being pro
anti-choice pro-life as they call it to
run for president
and he's been divorced and he's cheated
and he's not religious he never went to
church but i don't know now he says he
likes the bible okay even though it's
obvious that trump doesn't meet any of
their requirements remember they hate
hillary
they're not going to vote for the for
the democrats so they go we'll accept it
we'll accept trump's bogus story about
how he came to be against abortion and
will
accept trump's bogus story about how now
he's religious and two corinthians and
all of that and then it's proven to be
false time and time again
and they just go oh yeah well no but we
it doesn't matter i mean hillary was
even worse hillary's just absolutely
terrible it's never actually about any
of the things they claim it's about it
never is it's just a justification to
create a context to keep voting for the
people that say the right things even if
they're completely unbelievable now it
this will be a test for herschel walker
in georgia georgia has become very sort
of weaponized trumpist as we saw
but at the same time in the in some of
the primaries in georgia the trump
endorsed candidate didn't win and even
though trump did endorse herschel walker
this may be too much for these georgia
voters now the funny thing about it is
i would be willing to accept
if herschel walker from the beginning
did a sort of do as i say not as i do
thing
i don't think that that's completely
illegitimate i don't i like i would be
willing to accept someone being up
upfront and saying listen i think that
we have a problem
in general or in the black community
however he wants to phrase it with
absentee fathers and unfortunately i'm a
part of that problem i did xyz
and i'm not in touch with these kids and
it's it's been bad for me and it's been
bad for the kids and it's been bad for
the mothers and uh i am going through a
journey of personal rediscovery and i am
trying to make amends and fixing
you you guys know what i'm saying if he
just owned it i think you could still
credibly say and because i know this
issue so personally
it's a really important one that i want
to work on that's not what he did okay
he didn't do that and so now there's
going to be a question as to whether
this is the straw that breaks the
camel's back with these georgia voters i
don't know if it's going to be but we're
going to follow it and we will see
a rudy giuliani who was recently accused
of being drunk on election night during
which he told donald trump just claimed
that you won and gave him all sorts of
other authoritarian advice that led to
months and months and really at this
point years of trump and others
insisting that trump actually won rudy
giuliani initially tweeted that he was
not drunk on election night and he has
quietly deleted those tweets the obvious
speculation is
rudy deleted the tweets because there's
going to be undeniable evidence that
rudy was actually drunk out of his mind
on election night so um let's go through
this piece by piece
rudy giuliani deletes tweets denying he
was drunk on election night
explosive claim was made by fellow
campaign staffer so as a reminder i know
many of you already saw this clip one of
the big things at the start of the
second day of hearings with the trump
riot committee was liz cheney explaining
that rudy giuliani in an inebriated
state was the one telling trump just
declare victory you will hear firsthand
testimony that the president's campaign
advisers urged him to await the counting
of votes and not to declare victory on
election night
the president understood even before the
election that many more biden voters had
voted by mail because president trump
ignored the advice of his campaign
experts and told his supporters only to
vote in person
donald trump knew before the election
that the counting of those mail-in
ballots in several states
would not begin until late in the day
and would not be complete for multiple
days
this was expected reported and widely
known
you will also hear testimony that
president trump rejected the advice of
his campaign experts on election night
and instead followed the course
recommended by an apparently inebriated
rudy giuliani right to just claim he won
and insist that the vote counting stop
to falsely claim everything was
fraudulent yep okay so
initially rudy giuliani tweeted
refuting denying these claims rudy
tweeting um not long ago quote i am
disgusted and outraged at the outright
lie by jason miller and bill stephen i
was upset that they were not prepared
for the massive cheating as well as
other lawyers around the president i
refused all alcohol that evening my
favorite drink diet pepsi is the false
testimony from miller and stephen
because i yelled at them are they being
paid to lie well rudy giuliani has now
deleted those tweets
rudy giuliani has deleted two tweets
in which
the former mayor and attorney for trump
denied being drunk as votes rolled in on
election night and advising the
president to declare victory the two
tweets disappeared from giuliani's
timeline sometime tuesday evening
um what is the most simple explanation
for this well the simplest explanation
is someone is going to come forward with
specific knowledge of rudy being drunk
that night either it's video he's he
said very not only did see here's the
problem not only did rudy deny being
drunk he said he refused all alcohol so
because rudy went above and beyond in
his denial if there is any evidence that
he had any alcohol that night he now is
a liar you could say i was not drunk i
had a drink i was not drunk and then if
someone comes forward and says here's a
picture of rudy with a drink you're not
necessarily an obvious liar rudy still
is a liar of course but you're not
necessarily an obvious liar here it's a
different thing where rudy said i
refused alcohol the entire evening now
as a reminder
we're not making fun of alcoholism if
that is something rudy struggles with
there are widespread reports that during
the trump presidency
uh the schedulers around trump started
booking rudy giuliani for morning tv
shows rather than evening because it
turned out that in the evenings he would
allegedly show up drunk after having a
bunch of drinks at dinner uh we also
have videos like this one which again i
know some of you have seen but where he
he genuinely seems completely wasted
can imagine tony blanken or miley
how's that guy a general
jesus
the other day he said that the bagram
air force base is not strategically
important
i wanted to grab his what he had five
stars 10 stars 12 stars he has so many
stars they're coming up into his ears
i wanted to grab his stars shove it down
his throat and say it's 400 miles from
china [ __ ]
china yeah so anyway the real issue here
is there were people on election night
around trump telling him the truth which
is you lost but trump ignored all of
them and just accepted what he wanted to
hear from an allegedly drunk rudy
giuliani which is you you probably won't
just go out and declare victory that's
the really crazy part of the story
rudy deleting the tweets just points
more in the direction of the testimony
being accurate we have a voicemail
number that number is 2192 david p my
story from the bonus show about french
toast challah uh i'm sorry holla french
toast um
got the eggman thinking back to his time
in prison as many of you know the
eggman's been calling into the show for
15 years and he spent some time in
prison for drug related charges
and uh he often has interesting stories
here's one of them
i would kill for some french fred holla
right now hey dave when i was in prison
because i was a jew i made the chala
bread for the jewish guys right so i
would go in the kitchen you know once a
week maybe every couple weeks please
freeze a couple and when i'd make it
we'd add in the yeast except only the
guards could
have power over the yeast so they would
dump this yeast in this big mix they'd
even mix it in a little bit so we
couldn't take it out of course i would
take it out and i would trade it to the
native americans they would make alcohol
with their yeast that i gave them and
then they would trade us uh cannabis so
the jews would get high on shabbat
instead of you know have gurkhallah
however with half the yeast alcala still
came out and it was still okay we did a
good job
your baby and makala were both um items
shalom brother all right so the egg man
with an explosive look at
the trading that took place when he was
uh when he was in prison
we should really have eggman on he has
the best stories i know he wants to keep
himself private but i think he could he
could tell us some very interesting
stories we have a great bonus show
coming up for you today sign up at
joinpacman.com to get instant access to
the bonus show
you